Nekem ez volt az egyik legfőbb dilemmám,
amikor el kellett dönteni,
hogy belevágjak ebbe az egész
történetbe, vagy nem, hogy azt hallottam
az önkormányzati képviselőtől, azt
hallottam belső információkból és a
hivatalból, hogy óriási hiteleket kell
felvegyen a város, mert nagyon rossz
gazdálkodás zajlott és nagyon rossz
pályázatok
hívottak le, amikre nem feltétlenül volt
új jelentkezés, mertogy mások látták
azt, hogy ezeknek lesznek
hátulütői. És aztán azt mondtam, hogy
ennek ellenére is valaki most el kell
vállalja ezt a ezt a nehéz szerepet.
Láttam benne kiívást és igent mondtam,
és így valahogy miután megnyertük, én is
megnyugodtam, és azt mondtam, hogy hát
mert hogy arról szólt minden, hogy
egyébként nincsen adóssága a városnak,
hogy nincsenek kifizetlen számlák. Még
úgy vettem át gyakorlatilag elődömtől,
hogy volt egy
ilyen adásvétel gyakorlatilag, ahol
szintén elmondta, hogy egyébként itt
nincsen adósság, nincsen hitel, nem kell
felvenni semmiféle kölcsönt, minden
rendben van pénzügyi szempontból. És hát
aztán eltelt kettő hét még még az első
héten sem idegeskedtem, és a második
héten már jöttek a kollégák, hogy na
akkor megérkeztek a számlák.
لا